la noche del 26 de abril de 1986 una
explosión en la central nuclear de
Chernobyl dio lugar al mayor desastre
nuclear de la historia
31 personas fallecieron en el instante
mientras que las víctimas por la
radiación escalaron alrededor de 115.000
37 años después los ex trabajadores de
Chernobyl aún recuerdan ese día y no
olvidan a los compañeros que perdieron
la vida usando tenemos una tradición
desde hace 30 años todas las noches del
26 de abril venimos aquí ponemos flores
conozco a todos aquí era mi turno en la
planta de energía
estoy aquí para conmemorar a mis colegas
todos están vivos mientras yo los
recuerde
él es Boris arte actual ingeniero jefe
de la planta nuclear donde trabaja hace
40 años también recuerda esos días y
ahora su rol es controlar los procesos
vinculados con El Refugio del reactor
actualmente solo hay tres estaciones en
funcionamiento aquí dos están ubicadas
en el margen izquierdo depripiat pero no
hay acceso allí los puentes están todos
destruidos tres estaciones están
operando actualmente todas las demás
compresas funcionan normalmente ahora no
hay violaciones condiciones y criterios
para operaciones seguras usados
diversas homenajes se llevaron a cabo
este miércoles en que el presidente
ucraniano bola de selenski hizo un acto
conmemorativo y entregó flores en un
monumento a los fallecidos
mientras que funcionarios visitaron la
planta
si bien el área de Chernobyl está bajo
control el polvo radiactivo continúa en
el suelo y lo transformó en un lugar
Inevitable para los humanos